hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
part of the agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is bear i'm from biotech a part
of agilent and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of today's presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation you may also use to ask
a question box to submit your concerns
after the completion of the q a portion
of this presentation our speaker will be
available for more questions in the
networking area of the virtual
conference
from 12 30 pm to 1pm eastern standard
time
i now present today's speaker
christopher pudney
associate professor of biochemistry at
the university of bath
for complete biography on dr pudney
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
chris you may now begin your
presentation
hey and i'm here today to talk to you
about a technology we actually developed
in my lab which we call
cubes so i'm an associate professor of
biochemistry
at the university of bath and you know
i'm really excited actually to be able
to share
an innovation we've been working on for
really
quite some years now um you know i think
we probably had the
earliest seed of the idea for this
technology in 2016 and and
you know i guess it's nice to say that
even though we're in the
you know middle of the global pandemic
we've managed to really now bring it
through to fruition so
our technology which we call cubes is an
approach for rapidly predicting
the stability of proteins and i'm going
to show you a bunch of
you know really the science how that
works
but also what we can use it for what we
think we can use it for
you know my lab is a lab that's all
about trying to measure
the importance or understand the
importance of protein motion and
flexibility to biological function
and that's a little bit of a challenge
because the tools that we have to track
protein flexibility
are very small indeed and you know
there's some great examples like nmr
but they're not things we can really use
routinely or really at scale
so as i said we've developed a platform
for doing that and we very quickly
realized that being able to predict
flexibility actually could have some
really good
big implications in some different
sectors so really we feel like the
problem that actually our technology is
addressing
is this issue of the paucity of
technologies for tracking and
measuring stability uh particularly in
biopharmaceuticals
so the issue that we face really is the
and
the proteins are inherently unstable you
know your body makes
a lot of proteins and it purposely makes
those proteins to not be very stable
so we we say in the community proteins
are really only stabilized by the energy
of a few hydrogen bonds and that's
really low energy
and the reason for that is so that
biology can turn over those proteins
very quickly
use them clear them out get the next
thing in
that's a massive problem when you want
to make a protein as a
product or even a drug so let's think
about therapeutic monoclonal antibodies
some of the best drugs in the entire
world
deeply impressive molecules and there's
an example on the screen right there in
blue of an antibodies that's kind of the
structure of antibody and they're
enormous they're absolutely enormous
that makes them very prone to
aggregation and they're incredibly
mobile and flexible and again that makes
them very prone to aggregation that is
they're a very unstable molecule and
anyone that's ever worked in the lab
with antibodies as kits will know that
if you leave it out the fridge for any
period of time or if you look at it
slightly wrong
you know the the western blood or
whatever doesn't work anymore so they're
really unstable molecules
so to take these molecules and turn them
into drugs one of the key issues you
face is developing the stability
however there are no i would argue as a
protein biochemist
there are really no great solutions
individually for either tracking
stability and in fact there is no way to
predict
the stability in a sort of reasonable
means
uh for these kinds of proteins
and so we developed in the technology
that and i'll talk about how it works
but particularly the tracks molecular
flexibility and we can use this
technology to make predictions
about the stability of a protein and the
changing stability of the pro
of a protein and indeed this so this is
a
software solution that takes a simple
experimental measurement of protein
fluorescence tryptophan fluorescence and
proteins
and it converts that to a prediction of
stability
we'll talk about you know the ins and
outs of that but something that for us
as scientists is really important is
that
it's very easy to make the experimental
measurement this is based on
but you can really use it with any
protein at any concentration
and indeed any formulation that you like
there's no surface attachment
you can do the temperature that you want
to do so it's got a lot of things that
as a you know i guess
in my lab how we develop this really
that the tool and the technique that we
need and wanted
what i want to talk a lot about today is
the benchmarking
against existing approaches and really
show data from
other entities other than my own lab
show how this work and indeed you know
we publish work now on a bunch of
different proteins so monoclonal
antibodies and
and enzymes and peptides and regulatory
proteins and that literature is out
there for anyone to see
you know this solution at least
academically in my lab
it really works so well that actually we
spun out a company around this
uh from the university of bath in late
2019
um really to commercialize the software
solution that we developed
we spent most of that period i guess of
the last six months is making our
software cloud hosted and easily
accessible and all that kind of stuff
so this slide deals with an important
issue
you know as as protein biochemists or
protein scientists we're used to using a
big
range of different experimental
approaches to track
what's going on with our protein and so
often we care about structural change
right so we care about unfolding and
aggregation
and the tools that we have to track
structural change are quite varied and
they really each
as a broad brush tackle one aspect of
structure so
i've got it kind of up there right
primary structure secondary tertiary
quaternary structure
and there'll be an approach which is
good for one of those and probably not
so good for the others so
you know everybody loves to use cd and
cd is really powerful for looking at
secondary structural changes
uh in your protein um and then we can go
out to stuff like auc which is really
really powerful for looking
uh quaternary structures so aggregation
of your protein or light scattering
you know in the middle we've got maybe
some approaches then we can think of
many more approaches other than this
but in the middle we've maybe got some
approaches there which do a
lot do double duty so nmr can do
structural work
and work on protein dynamics
as can mass spec and x-ray really gives
you that detailed atomistic insight into
your three-dimensional structure
those approaches really we aren't maybe
using quite as day-to-day as we would
like to because
most proteins you can't really nmr
because they're too big that's changing
over time i know x-ray is not
necessarily high throughput solve
structures for everything that you want
to see particularly in formulation
because you can't really scan
formulations with x-ray
a mass spec has quite a big capex cost
and it's quite technically difficult
so we're in a landscape where we can
study something about protein structure
but we really need to use a bunch of
different techniques and you guys that
work in formulation you guys that work
in development will know this you'll use
an absolute bunch of techniques to try
and build up a story and a picture of
what your protein is like
but you're interested i think maybe
you're interested my interest is in
stability of proteins
and we try and use these approaches
which is structural biology approaches
really to try and then
infer something about stability so maybe
we do a temperature ramp to get out
delta g
for unfolding or even aggregation we
look at aggregation propensity over time
and we try and get some metric of
stability what we end up with
is a handful of things handful of
metrics and we try and make a decision
the approach that we've developed and
i'll talk about it
in a second in some detail tracks
molecular flexibility
so that's what we sense we don't send
secondary structure tertiary structure
quaternary structure we sense
changes in molecular dynamics molecular
flexibility and we can see an example
that's an antibody moving around there's
a
really low level of motion for
antibodies they're very flexible
because we track something about
molecular flexibility we're actually
able
to track any change in structure
so anytime there's a change in
quaternary tertiary or secondary
structure
by definition something about the
molecules flexibility changes
and indeed we can see those changes
a great example and it's a different
story for another time
is we can see the difference in
flexibility between
proteins that have an identical crystal
structure so we had a great study where
we with a collaborator had the structure
of
uh a wild type enzyme and a point
variant single amino acid
and the crystal structures are
absolutely identical all the molecular
dynamics simulations told us one was
more rigid than the other
and indeed our approach picked up that
change experimentally
so that's identical structures but
tracking just that change in molecular
flexibility that's how powerful this
approach is
all right flexibility you know i talk
about stability and flexibility almost
interchangeably
and that's because in a thermodynamic
sense in a really fundamental academic-y
sense they are
any kind of small molecule as it gets
more flexible
it will tend to become more
thermodynamically unstable and that's
just a truism of
basic thermodynamics right it becomes
more rigid it becomes more physically
stable and that's almost quite intuitive
right
and that's how our technology is really
able to predict protein stability by
tracking changes in molecular
flexibility i'm going to show you some
some examples of that just a second
you know i really did want to um
delve into the science a little bit
because you know i never know how much
people want to know
so so i i just want to spend a couple of
slides telling you how this thing works
and to almost dispel how you think it
works because almost no one's heard
of the approach that we use in the way
in which we use it
so let's talk about fluorescence so this
approach is based on tracking
intrinsic protof protein fluorescence so
looking really at
tryptophan emission not in the way that
you're thinking that so on the top left
of this figure we have basic
fluorescence right we have
you absorb a photon light your
fluorophore gets excited you
lose a bit of energy through a bunch of
mechanisms and then you emit a photon
which is the blue arrow going down there
right you have fluorescence
there's something called the cacha
vavalov rule which tells us
that it doesn't really matter what
wavelength we use to excite our
fluorophore
you know we almost always use a
wavelength where to the peak of the
absorption of the fluorophore just gives
us a bigger signal
but it doesn't matter what wavelength we
use uh the structure of our emission
spectra will always be the
same so the shape of the emission
spectral won't change and that's panel b
in the figure that i've got right we can
hit it anywhere on the absorption
spectrum in blue
and all right the intensity will change
but the structure of the emission
spectrum will be exactly the same the
shape will be the same
under some conditions we can get a
breakdown of the cache of avaloveral
and so for example if you've got a
fluorophore that's sampling a bunch of
different
environments it's possible that we can
start to
photo select for discrete energy levels
discrete emissive energy levels by
changing the energy of our excitation
now each of those discrete environments
will have a characteristic emission
spectrum associated
emission spectrum associated with it and
so what we see where we have this kind
of moving around of a fluorophore
sampling a bunch of different
environments
we see that we have what's called the
red edge excitation
shift phenomenon that is as we decrease
the energy of excitation
the shape of our emission spectra
changes and that's shown in panel c
there so
we start to move along the absorption
spectrum
uh to the right to lower energy
excitations
uh and we just do that by increasing the
wavelength very easy with the excitation
light
and something about the shape and the
structure of our mission spectra changes
and it gets broader
in a specific way and that's called the
red edge excitation shift phenomenon
that was really characterized really
beautifully by
a japanese group in the 70s you probably
kind of three back to
back papers on this which are like the
bible right you know they're wonderful
uh papers and it was you know taken on
um
by a bunch of other groups notably uh in
india who really
produced some beautiful protein data
using this approach and still do i have
to say
something i want to say is you know you
guys are aficionados of fluorescence in
the audience this is
not a solvatochromatic effect that is
something quite different this is an
excitation energy dependent effect all
right so we leave the the you know the
optical physics there now but that's the
basis of the approach
what we're able to do is use this
approach this kind of
i guess tracking how many environments
our fluorophore can see
we can use that approach to infer
something about protein flexibility so
imagine
how tryptophan is our fluorophore
sampling different environments it's
moving
it's flexible if we can track something
about
how many environments it can experience
we can tell you how flexible it is
so the more environments it can
experience the more flexible it is the
smaller number of environments
the more rigid it is conceptually right
let's look at some data now and then
really how we how we track this and then
i'll show you some real evidence
you know what we do is and so you know
how to make the measurement you know
it's published
it's out there in our literature and
it's freely available so you can go and
take a look in fact we're publishing a
book chapter on this
uh hopefully out fairly soon so which
delves into the detail how to make the
measurements it's very easy
we measure tryptophan protein tryptophan
emission spectrum
and that on the left-hand panel there is
what tryptophans look like in proteins
very roughly
as an emission spectrum we then decrease
the energy of the excitation wavelength
we use so we scan we
just increase the excitation wavelength
in one nanometer increments
and you can see that our emission
spectra as we change that excitation
wavelength
starts to get a bit fatter they go out
towards the green spectrum they get
broader
that's our red edge excitation shift
phenomena
we want to now quantify something about
how that shape of that spectrum is
changing and there are a bunch of ways
to do that and the simplest easiest and
frankly the most reproducible way
is to measure what's called the center
of spectral mass and that's
kind of where the heaviest weight of the
emission spectra is on the x-axis there
so we can then plot on our middle panel
there the center of spectral mass
csm which tells us something about the
shape of our spectrum versus the change
in the excitation
wavelength so as we increase that
wavelength we're going to lower energies
and you can see now how that kind of
panelated panel be
really changes that center of spectral
mass moves to the red of the spectrum
higher wavelengths and we can see that
curves upwards and that's what all
red edge excitation shift spectra really
do look like apart from some very niche
cases
the way this was tackled historically
was
we didn't really have a physical model
or an underpinning or an understanding
of how this approach worked
what it was telling us maybe we
understood what it might be able to tell
us but getting to that information
wasn't really possible
the way we were tackling this data was
we were saying well
you know i'll subtract the top number
from the bottom number and that's my
effect right essentially putting a
straight line through the data and i've
done that here i've put a straight line
through that gray data
and you can see it doesn't work very
well
where we came into this story i think of
this optical phenomenon is you know from
fundamental protein thermodynamics we
said and i went too much more in
fundamental protein thermodynamics i
promise we're 30 more seconds
where we came in we said well you know
we know something about distributions of
energies and states as they pertain to
protein-friendly landscapes
and so you know we kind of started to
think about physical models that we
could develop and use
to fit these data and then our curve
line now that red code line is our model
that we
our math that we like to use that inform
us that
really unlock the power of these data
if we take the math from that and we
plot it in three dimensional space which
is now the far right panel there
we we can see we get a spot and that
spot
is a very sensitive very accurate metric
of the protein's flexibility it's
exactly like a fingerprint
if the pro anything changes about the
molecular flexibility or into the
structure
excuse me of our protein something about
that spot will change
and we call this the cubes a
quantitative understanding of
biomolecular edge
shift it's a good long sciency name i
hope you can agree with me
so we have a spot and it's a fingerprint
of flexibility
and i'll show you now and the evidence i
think evidence-based
for how we use that and that it really
works the way we say it works
here's just a real summary and just a
conceptual overview really summarizes a
lot of science i have to say
is how we use this spot this fingerprint
so the raw data that we might collect
and this is real raw data
on the left here is the change in the
emission spectrum
with the change in the excitation
wavelength for a protein
that gives us a spot on what we found
through an awful lot of work we and i
have to say with a lot of collaborators
who were very generous to us and gave us
a lot of material and a lot of support
and advice
particularly relating to antibodies and
we're able to come up with a model for
not just how to treat these data but
then what they're telling us
and so we now understand that the
direction our spot moves in
tells us what's happening to our
proteins so if it goes in the green
direction our proteins getting
stabilized because it's getting more
rigid if it goes in the blue direction
it's getting uh more destabilized
because it's getting more flexible
and remember i said to you that because
we're tracking changes in molecular
flexibility really we're sensitive to
any change um
in structure and so actually we can
detect structural change right
outside the you know state stability is
you know outside of any structural
change
we can tell if the protein is unfolding
and we can even tell if the protein
is starting to form soluble like
subvisible
aggregates i think really exciting
okay so let's look at the application
now of this idea and and i'm really
wanting to look at
other people's data not data from our
lab you know that's all more than the
published domain and i want to show you
some other people's data
oh yeah before i do that you know it's
worth saying because this was a huge
part of the journey is
that taking that idea in and
commercializing it now and spinning out
a company block labs around
that is now a cloud-hosted platform uh
and and
you know that's available and if you
want to talk to us about the use of that
then then
then do go ahead that's not really what
i want to talk about today that i have
to say
let's show some evidence let's show some
data so i said that we can predict
protein stability it's an enormous claim
it really is an enormous claim because
there isn't really anything you could
use routinely that can
predict protein stability you know maybe
nmr maybe nmr
um but you can't really routinely do nmr
and so this if it works well
could be enormous because all of a
sudden all of that energy and effort
that one has to expend
that three months of work to try and
work out the stability of a bunch of
different molecules you care about
you can do in a day and now i know
people don't want to use it in that way
but certainly it can augment
what you're doing we like to think that
it can make it faster you know use those
complex approaches that take a lot of
time and cost
use them less right but but maybe that's
for downgrade let me show you the data
so these data were taken from a paper we
published uh just really recently
actually it's freely available there's a
link and we published that with ucb so
michael knight who's the first author
there he uh used our approach in their
labs
over in slough in the uk at that site of
ucb's
uh and they had a bunch of maps that you
know
we don't get told anything about and
that's all right one to three
uh and you know mike said to me well
look we've got this
set of antibodies that we've just had
sat
uh you know under conditions for six
months to assess the really long-term
stability because how do you assess
long-term stability right
you just leave it out for six months and
see what happens to it he said i'd be
curious if we make
a measurement of our samples at time
equals zero so before we've left them
out
if you predict the stability trend and
then we see if that tallies are what we
see after six months long term stability
so on the left now is our spot and mike
made these measurements
this is not us making this this is ucb
making these measurements on mike
specifically and he's a fantastic
scientist
he gave us all he had three molecules
one to three and
without going into too much depth you
know the data suggests that
three is the most stable then one and
then two is the least stable
mike actually measured these at a couple
of different temperatures so 15 and 40
degrees and those are the
second spot that you see there so as you
increase the temperature
you give the system more energy and it
gets more flexible so it gets less
stable and that's indeed what what our
cubes tend to say and we do temperature
studies all the time it's good
to track things so we've got our
prediction right
three then one then two so two is the
worst let's now look at the panel
uh b now so i've really simplified this
measurement we don't really use it this
way but it's a nice simple way to look
at it
so on the y-axis now the smaller the
value
the more stable we predict the molecule
to be let's say that
and on the x-axis is mike's data of
six-month stability looking at the
fractional loss of the monomer so
after six months number three loses 0.9
percent
after six months two loses 1.8
so we can see that our prediction is
correct three is the most stable
it has the lowest loss of fractional
loss of monomer and two is the least
stable
so we're absolutely right we are
predicting stability and i really make
this point that this is
six month stability data you can only
get these data
well this trend before by doing the six
months worth of work
now you don't have to or maybe you
choose to augment your studies with
something like this
to choose your best conditions
there are two things here that are
really important and that again
mike did at ucb and his idea to do this
study
can this approach see the differences
that different physical perturbations
make
so not just temperature but the whole
suite of things you care about when you
care about the stability of a molecule
so
light exposure chemical changes like
dehamidation on oxidation yes of course
temperature
shaking you know just that basic one of
shaking really important
um ph right these are common things but
can we see those differences are we
sensitive to those things
and then are we sensitive to them in the
same way
that all of the other you know bajillion
approaches that you might want to use
are
so first we've got over here so this is
from a forced degradation study of one
of my
antibodies and on the left here we've
got our spots
and we can see that our spots are in
different places for different
conditions that have been used and again
in panel b i've just simplified that
down so
you know the higher the number on the
y-axis
the less stable the protein is and so
we've got that versus all the conditions
and we can see yeah our spot moves
around in a way that is specific
uh to the condition and it makes some
predictions about
what are the least perturbing uh
conditions and what the most perturbing
conditions and again this is a this is a
rabbit measurement this is like 10
minutes
time equals zero whatever temperature
you want to conduct on that unless you
remember the temperature series
so what we're saying is that you know a
lot of light is really bad on the top
right of that figure
unsurprisingly you know light's dreadful
for proteins really uh high temperature
unsurprisingly particularly bad really
low protein ph
uh it's not very good either and we can
see some temperature effects and some
other effects like oxidation
in there as well deomidation are not
good maybe unsurprisingly
you know the things that don't change
the protein very much maybe not a
shocker
is keeping it in the fridge you know ph
is the starts to get a bit more alkaline
generally out antibodies a bit more
tolerance when alkaline ph
let's look now at a range of other
approaches and what they say to us so if
we use both sec and auc so our
quaternary structure approaches
uh that we've got in panel c there we
can see that
um the things that aren't good or
cause you to aggregate essentially uh
are
high temperature 50 degrees a lot of
light and particularly low ph you know
those are the things that give some
between second auc give the same result
effectively right
that's exactly what our cube's approach
predicts a lot of light high temperature
and low ph let's look at it so that's
cortana structure right let's look at
tertiary structure so
let's look at you know differential
scanning calorimetry
it's okay for for um tertiary structure
the thing these all this shows basically
no difference apart from three
conditions and those three conditions
are oxidation
uh low ph and uh really high temperature
right
so this is only sensitive to three
conditions and we ping all those
conditions and more with our approach
if we then go and look at cd if we use
five uv cd to look at secondary
structure
there's no difference there is no
secondary structural change to these
proteins that we can detect by cd
if we use near uv cd there's a bit
better at looking at
tertiary structure maybe there are some
differences particularly with 50 degrees
c but it's not quite pinging them in the
same way that dsc did
so we can see that our approach captures
that full range
of not just prediction so it gets the
right answers
but it captures that full range of
uh understanding that actually we had to
use here for
five different approaches to achieve so
maybe that gives you that sense
of the power of this approach
i want to go on now to to look at
something that we've thought about for a
very long time so in my lab we have
a bench top fluorimeter and the nice
thing about this measurement is you can
just use
pretty much a standard bench top
florimeter
they cost you know what us not even 20
000. it's one of the cheapest
instruments that you can buy
um and most places have a bench top
fluorometer
they have a cell holder in it and you
take a one mil quartz cuvette
and you pop it in and you make your
measurement clear it out put the next
one in clear it out put the next one in
and because it's a rapid measurement
you're there for i don't know 10 minutes
something like that you need a human
being
changing it over every 10 minutes and my
students don't like that
it turns out they want to they want to
have a high relaxation quotient in their
lives and they don't want to be it's
laborious right it's boring
and it wastes a human's time just
putting a thing in and out
of equality so we have this real
interest in seeing
if we could make these measurements
maybe not high throughput but certainly
medium throughput certainly certainly 96
well platable
so plate reader technology right and
there are a bunch of different
fluorescence plate readers out there i
love fluorescence right
and whenever we have a collaborator they
always want to use a plate reader to
make measurements either if they're you
know kinetic measurements or not even
our measurements other measurements we
always want to use play reader
when i say no we're just going to make
them one at a time the highest quality
measurement we possibly can one mil
quartz cube it's laborious but we get
better data because the reality is for a
bench top perimeter
the detector is better the lamps better
the alignments are better the optics are
a better quality and they're just laid
out better there's a reason they're
enormous
because you get better quality data out
of them so the vast majority of plate
readers
just don't have the sensitivity we need
and remember what we're trying to do is
capture something about the shape of the
spectra so we need accurate data here
yeah we don't care about intensity it's
just completely unimportant to us what
the intensity of the spectra are
we care about shape so we want a really
good fluorimeter
and it's just true that most plate
readers because they're not designed for
making that kind of measurement just
don't do that
and we had a i can't remember how it
came about but we got some tip off
about an instrument from um biotech so
then
synergy neo2 system which is a plate
reader
but it's like a benchtop fluorimeter
crammed into a plate reader
and so i had the question here we'd
always wanted to see if we can really
make these measurements kind of 96 more
platable
set it up in the evening go home go to
sleep your just data's
there ready in the morning
and this was you know in the middle of a
raging
pandemic that we reached out to biotech
and said look would you mind terribly
we'd love to have a look at this and see
if it's possible would you would you
lend us an instrument
and um you know they happened to have
one so we were very very fortunate i
know they were doing a lot of covet
testing with those instruments so we
were grateful to get the loan
but we we had to try and at the same
time you know we were working with
a company to look at formulation of um
peptide and unfortunately i can't talk
about that right now it's something
we're going to be publishing pretty soon
but
it's not quite ready yet so i'm afraid i
can't go into the details but we were
making that with them so we said we'll
do this study on the neo2 and see if it
can really work
so i want to show you that data now um
and here's the raw data that we
collected for one of our conditions on
the left and you can see
it looks like a tryptophan emission
spectrum there's a lot i can say about
how we got to these data but the point
is we got there
and the concentration isn't very high
you know it's not we can't go quite as
high or quite
low in excuse me low in concentration uh
with this plate reader as we can with a
benchtop instrument but it's pretty
close so where i might like to work at a
micro molar
maybe on this instrument i could get up
to about 20 micromolar probably a little
bit lower to be honest
but the spectra look great and you know
on the right hand panel there that's a
numerical model of what
you know the simulation of what the
perfect spectrum will be
and we can see it's pretty good right so
we had high confidence in the raw data
from this instrument
let me show you what we did so
we collected some data and we got this
red edge excitation
shift phenomenon this upward curvature
this changing shape of the spectra as we
expect and we fit our model through
because we're on a plate reader now we
were able to do a formulation study
so we were able to take uh the same
protein
under a bunch of different formulation
conditions a very broad range of
conditions and this was interesting yeah
this is why we're publishing this one or
you'll see it soon enough
is because it was a failed failed
molecule that didn't go
uh through to clinical trials but it
came you know it came pretty close
um and there are this was at the end of
that formulation cycle where
really they were close on what they
thought was the best they could make it
and then they're just tweaking around in
the margins to try and just really
optimize it so any differences we see
here or if we can see differences it's
really impressive because it's about as
good as it can be already
so we had this neo team we had the plate
reading we felt the raw data were good
so we ran this study
of 24 in fact we did 26 different
formulations uh
of this molecule using the neo2 and
there are spots on the right
that's the output of our spots and what
we can see
straight away is that our spots aren't
in the same place
so we are seeing differences in
flexibility and therefore stability
for most of these formulations um
noting that it's already pretty good you
know there's not a lot of difference
going on now so we're really separating
out we're really teasing out
uh these differences but let's show it
versus the you know the trends we expect
so here's the here's the data um you
know
ranked in the way that we ranked it so
we rank stability
and we said you know are we right so we
can see here uh you know again it's
quite trivialization of the data to show
this
y-axis the way we do but it's it's
convenient for us to look at you know as
that number gets smaller we've got
increasing stability and the little uh
the number one that's got the red star
over it that's our reference so so we
have a reference and we want to
understand how stability is changing
relative to a reference
so we can see that number one was
somewhere in the middle of the pack
maybe not the middle of the pack but
there are a bunch of things that made
the stability worse so particularly 18
22 23
particularly 18 was really bad uh or
relatively bad
but we can see we've got a bunch of
slightly better hits we've got a bunch
of improvements on stability and i
particularly know you know we got the
right kind of trend here
by comparing to a full range of other
experimental approaches which took a
long time to collect that data
yeah so we got the right trend in fact
number nine which is predicted to be the
best that was exactly the same one
that's predicted to be the best by using
a full range of other approaches
and that study took three months to
complete this took
says total collection time there seven
and a half hours i think that's probably
not quite right
i think it's probably more like 14 hours
seven and a half hours for the protein
and then we collect the buffer
measurements as well but it was an
overnight
measurement you know wanting to be real
about that it was the middle of a global
pandemic i was the only person that
could go into work
so i actually did some science if you
can believe that and my students were a
bit shocked uh
i just put it on came in in the art i
picked my girls up from school when my
partner came home
zipped up to work made a 964 plate and
pressed go
i came back the next day and there's my
data and i did in
overnight what it took three months to
achieve
using that full range of other
approaches and we got the right trend
and we predicted the right winner
okay let's look at how we rank it it's
important because i want to talk about
this other feature of this approach
and and maybe different modalities of
use so we ranked these samples based on
on you know which was best to worst and
you know it's not linear some of them
were pretty similar so there are a bunch
that we're all good
we say are good and a bunch that were
kind of really bad and we can see the
ones that were generally bad at you know
the eights and the nines we've got this
note next to them that says ag
which means aggregated you know i told
you that the software
and how we were structuring the data
allowed us not just to predict stability
changes but also
track changes and structure because
we're detecting flexibility so we should
be sensitive to structural change
particularly unfolding and aggregation
and you know it's a long story about how
that works and we can go into the depth
you know in some of our publications are
you welcome to ask me but we can see the
bottom three the least
stable predicted actually had the
software tells us some sub
visible like soluble aggregates
present and probably not very much quite
quite a low level but they were there
and they were present
and so it's not surprising why these
molecules really come down the bottom of
our list
because they're a little bit prone to
aggregation
let me let me talk a bit about you know
use conditions of the approach now i
hope i've shown you i'll really show you
a small slice of some of the data
you know if you've got a question about
use we've done and seen almost
everything i think
um so we've almost gotten always got an
example i wanted to focus on some really
key ones today
but let me just go through when you can
use it and some key points about this
approach
you really can use any buffer that you
like so you don't have to have low salt
you don't have to have you know a
specific ph you don't have to have a
specific buffering on we don't have a
unique solution that you have to swap
everything into you can use anything you
want anything that you're comfortable
using or that your protein likes right
so
i hate this idea of having 10 different
approaches and i have to change my
buffer or my formulation to suit the
approach
and then i'm trying to compare the data
from all of them doesn't make any sense
with this approach you pick the buffer
that you want to use and it's absolutely
fine
i showed you you can really use almost
any environmental perturbation you know
outside things like temperature which we
do like to do but
there are other things right like light
and agitation are really
crucial factors in understanding the use
and the stability of a molecule
particularly for the formulation
scientists there you can use
any excipient non-protein-based
excipient of course we're tracking
proteins
um we've done stuff with glucose and peg
and
everything that you like and we often
have the question well what if my
molecule if i've got an excipient that's
fluorescent
it's absolutely fine because we do a
buffer subtraction it just doesn't make
any difference to the data i'll speak on
that again in a second
temperature's a big one for me you know
i'm a
i guess protein thermodynamicist if
that's a thing
or at least i you know i love protein
thermodynamics i think it's really
important and valuable and insightful
and we use temperature all the time
because it's a good way to get to these
fundamental thermodynamic parameters
when you're trying to study protein
temperature is really hard work
because proteins aren't very stable to
temperature so you can do unfolding
studies
but for a lot of proteins as soon as you
unfold the protein that aggregates so
when you do a temporary temperature ramp
you unfold and you aggregate so what are
you looking at
so whilst i love temperature change as a
prohibitive thing
i don't think it's that sensible for
looking at stability i think you want to
have your protein
just happy happy buffer low temperature
as nice as it can be
and so with our approach you can take
any temperature your proteins happier
and we've done everything from five
degrees
up to 90 degrees with your
hypothermophilic enzymes that we like to
work with
so to be clear on this also it doesn't
matter what temperature you measure the
measure
make the measurement at as long as
you're consistently using the same
temperature and you don't do temperature
ramps with this approach right
one temperature the one that you like to
use
i think it's also important so you can
use pretty much any protein
concentration you want probably down to
about
you know low micrograms per mil is
probably where we start to get low
um but certainly into high milligrams
per ml so if you've got formulation and
you want to work at really high
concentrations
because again your formulation is at 50
mg per ml 100 mg per ml
most thing most most approach you have
to dilute that but concentration can be
really stabilizing through
macromolecular crowding so without
approach you can do any concentration
you want
i think it may be a technical point here
some people will say well what about
you know again for the aficionado in the
audience you know
what about the inner filter effect our
approach
doesn't care about fluorescence
intensity it's just not important we
care about the structure of the emission
spectrum
so we can work at any concentration that
gives good quality data
so i want to leave it there that's a lot
of information maybe not talk too long
and just to summarize on this and i hope
i've shown a little bit of data and
really
i hope you delivered some of our
excitement about the approach that we've
developed
and um we do hope that you want to give
it a try and we're really here to
support people to do that
give it a whirl almost guarantee you've
got an instrument that can make the
measurements and when we we're here to
support you to do that and if you
have a try the measurements we don't
have an instrument we're always happy to
do trials in our lab
with people and i do want to comment on
that and i hope it's not too cheesy to
say but
that biotech instrument was fantastic
i loved it um and
you know i'm pleased to say that the
partner we did that study with
i can't quite fully talk about it yet
but they had one right
in the in their labs and now they're
rocking and rolling with that instrument
which is great for us
uh and great for us that we can
recommend a plate reader that's really
high-end and can collect these data now
okay well thank you so much for
listening and i'm really grateful
to take any questions thank you
all right well thank you chris for that
informative presentation
uh we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
and you haven't done so please do so now
you can just click on the ask a question
box located at the far left of your
screen
let's get started uh looks like our
first question
is how long does it take to get the
predicted stability
that's right so that that's a great
great question and
and um really when we were using
we're making a relatively simple
experimental measurement here right i
said you can use pretty much
a basic standard fluorimeter if you like
and so the way we like to make the
measurement
something like 10 minutes maybe right
and then the question becomes well
i take a bunch of 10 minute data you
know how long does it take to do this
prediction bit how long does it take to
run out that math and all the rest of it
it's effectively instant so the way we
set things up is we
cloud hosted our piece of software and
so what you do is you can make your
measurements
and you can make as many measurements
you like and then you just drag and drop
an output file in the format that you
output uh onto
uh the software and it will do it all
pretty much instantly for you to get the
result
so receiving your results really fast
and something we thought really
carefully about is this idea of
um you know workflow right so when we're
in the lab
maybe we not me anymore i don't do lab
work anymore i'm not allowed to right
but
um when we're doing work in the lab you
maybe spend a day making measurements
and then you maybe just want to process
them the next day in the morning
and so the idea for us is you can keep
that drag and drop that whole set of
files dump them
onto the software and it just gives you
the result pretty much instantly and
that's what i did the idea i think of
um a rapid decision making tool right so
that you can really
on a day-to-day basis make the best
decisions that you can possibly make
all right thank you um our next question
is is there a technical guide on how to
make the measurements
yeah so i so this is a good one because
it looks hard right
and it and and i hope you've never even
heard of the
basic optical phenomenon that we use
because it's very niche
and so it sounds difficult and i think
it does look difficult
but actually once you've set the
measurement up
it couldn't be simpler and your own
instrument that you've got in your own
environment if you have a fluorimeter
there will be a setting on your
instrument that you'll pretty much
click and we'll give you some guidance
on how to you know
what to press to collect the raw data
that you need
i i accept that you know there are some
people also that don't work with protein
routinely day to day so some of you guys
will just work with protein all the time
and you'll do every every approach under
the sun and you're very
experienced analytically but if you know
for some people who just
want to do quality assurance they don't
work with protein every day
and and so we've produced a document
which is a really detailed guide for
just how to you know use a florimeter
and put the sample in and do all of that
and that's ready to send out to people
and we usually send that out when people
want to make measurements in their own
environment
and really that came out of us writing a
book chapter on the approach of how to
uh use the approach and collect the data
and any kind of technical detail that
you might need but
100 of the time by the time someone's
made their first measurement
they turn around they say that it's kind
of trivially easy right
yeah let's see well looks like we have
one more question for you today
um can we send you proteins for a test
for you to do yeah you should you should
and you should send us we love it right
so
you know if you've got an instrument in
your environment you're welcome to just
ask us and say you know is the kind of
work and we can tell you
um but if you don't have an instrument
in your environment and you want to try
it out
we're always happy to receive samples
and take a look at them
and um you know as long as that number
is not absolutely crazy we're happy to
have something and run out a little
study for you and if you want to test
out the approach and see if it works for
you we can help you kind of design a
i guess a study that will make sense for
you um
and i think if you know we always wanna
yeah i'm an academic right
and we love writing papers more than
anything i guess
and we always like to see if we can also
work collaboratively to make a paper so
if you want to do a bigger study and we
feel we can turn it into a collaborative
piece of work we're really happy to talk
about that as well
great it looks like we didn't just have
another one submitted so uh would the
cube's approach
be potent enough to validate protein to
protein interaction inhibitors
yeah such a great question and we focus
so much on stability and and you know
maybe you'll understand the reasons that
we do that
we the first thing that we ever did when
we published on this approach was
looked at the protein protein
interactions of a regulatory
human regulatory protein and it works
great
because you know you maybe will know
this that when a protein binds even to a
small molecule ligand
or another uh protein guess what
something about its flexibility changes
uh
and that can be have significant
biological function so absolutely yeah
you can use it to track
um we're going to interactions um
in exactly the same way you would for an
approach where you want to do like a
dose response curve right
absolutely what works in in that way and
if you've got a specific application in
mind
again love to talk to you about it and
just see if we can help you
make that measurement or or help produce
that
great well thank you for your time today
and your very important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via contact information that you
provided at the time of your
registration
if you have any other questions for
chris right now please join him in the
networking area of the virtual
conference
from right now until 1 pm eastern time
if you have any biotech specific product
questions please visit us in the biotech
booth found in the exhibit hall
this webcast will also be viewed on
demand
through july of 2021 so until next time
thank you and goodbye thanks guys
goodbye